I'm just making sure that we are all set
up hi everyone
I can see great people now in the room
on the chat fantastic okay so thank you
very much everyone for joining me today
let me know if you can't hear me I'm
hoping there are no problems all good
Jackie we would like your video back on
we are not able to see your video okay
hold on one moment can you see me now
yet you should all be able to see me now
great all right apologies about that
thank you all and I'm going to get
started with this webinar today so I'm
not sure how many of you that I have
engaged with but some of you may know me
my name is Jackie Lawrence and I'm one
of the career coaches at Udacity and
today I'd like to welcome you all to the
presentation which is called
how to build self-confidence for a
career change
so like I said and my name is Jackie
Lawrence and you know when it comes to a
career change it's actually a major
decision that you're making and it takes
a lot of effort thought and planning and
as you progress along the path there
will be times you may seriously question
and consider whether you're doing the
right thing and if you truly have the
ability to make the career shift so
today's webinar what we're going to do
is we're going to discuss what is
self-confidence how a lack of
self-confidence can hold you back from
reaching your potential in your chosen
field of work we will then go through
some of the important areas where the
ability to express yourself confidently
can be key to your success
then look at steps you can take to
develop your self-confidence in those
areas just to give you a bit of
background on a format of the session
I'm going to talk for about 40 to 45
minutes and then there will be time for
Q&A in the meantime while I'm doing the
session everyone will be muted to avoid
background noise as we go along if you
have any questions please type them in
the chat box I also have my co-host
mirror from Udacity here with me to
assist me with managing this webinar and
the chat box so you've probably seen her
she's been saying hi to everyone in the
chat box so without further ado let's
get started so moving onto slide a
little background about me as I
mentioned before I'm a career coach at
Udacity but I'm also a business strategy
and development coach helping
individuals and organizations to achieve
their business career and policy goals
helping them to unblock any issues
untangle themselves and to be able to
get to where they need to in their
business and their careers prior to
being a coach I actually spent 15 years
working as a lawyer in the financial
services industry and so I worked for
banks I worked in law firms I've worked
with senior teams and I've also worked
with junior teams I've worked globally
Dubai USA so I take along with me to my
coaching practice all my skills that
I've gained lot of and transferable
skills a word you probably heard a lot
about recently and I bring them all of
me along with my coaching tools and
skills to coaching and development so
without further ado let's move on and
let's go through today's agenda so you
can see the various topics that we are
going to cover today and this includes
sorry excuse me what is self confidence
how a lack of self confidence can hold
you back taking control of your
self-confidence
communicating with confidence looking
confident what does your body language
say about cheer building up confidence
for interviews confidence in the
workplace and then finally we'll have
some time for Q&A so just to get you all
warmed up and started we're going to
start this session off with a poll and
I'd be interested to know your thoughts
on this question so self-confidence you
either have it or you don't
how do you feel about this statement do
you number one think it's true
so if confidence something you're born
with or do you think number two is the
myth you're not born with it
self-confidence is a trait that can be
built up over time 3 do you think it's
partly true if you're born with it you
can develop it or number 4 are you
unsure so let me know your thoughts oh
wow yeah they're coming in good keep
them coming
great ah I can see the pole changing
there are a lot of you going through a
number two yep give it a couple more
seconds fool you okay okay there's 71
percent yeah bit more of you almost
there if we can get it up to a hundred
percent voting on this okay any more
okay we'll give it a couple more seconds
and then we're going to close this poll
great okay
thanks very let's close this poll so
results in number two at least 65% of
you believe it's a myth you're not born
with it self confidence is a trait that
can be built up over time 35% of you you
think it's partly true if you're born
with it you can develop it and 5% of you
are unsure well those of you who are in
the sixty five percent category it's a
myth you're absolutely correct self
confidence is not something you'll born
with we can
or develop err okay we may develop it at
different paces but we can all develop
it so what is self-confidence
well basically self-confidence is
something that's been debated and
discussed by a number of researchers in
orders for consistency I'm going to go
with the definition from the psychology
dictionary online and it defines
self-confidence as our self assurance in
trusting our abilities capacities and
judgment the belief that we can meet the
demands of tasks in other words to be
self confidence is to trust in your own
abilities and believe that we can do
what we set our minds to do so there you
go one of the definitions of self
confidence it's there trusting in
yourself and believing your own skills
your own gold and abilities to succeed
and the thing with that is when you
actually believe in yourself you're more
likely to take action grab opportunities
that come your way and when the going
gets tough you persevere because you
trust your instincts now self confidence
is not a static measure nobody is self
confident 100 percent of the time we all
sit on a barometer and our confidence to
perform roles and tasks and deal with
situation can increase and decrease
depending on our situation in our
environment some days we feel more
confident than others and for some of us
it just means that we have to work a
little harder in order to get our
confident level up but ultimately none
of us are born with it on all of us can
develop it over time so let's look at
next slide what zone are you in okay
this is a comfort zone charm so I'd like
you all to spend a minute or two just
looking at it and think about which
inner circle are you sitting in or where
do you spend more than 50% of your time
which color please type in the chat box
with stones you sitting also depends on
your own
Herman if you work remotely maybe you
sit in the comfort zone if you change
roles and have to go into an office a
couple of times a week you may move into
the fear zone so let's have your
thoughts anybody brave enough to let us
know what you're thinking the comfort
zone read the fear zone orange learning
zone yellow and the growth zone green to
a certain extent you all are in
definitely the yellow otherwise you
wouldn't be learning at UTS Udacity but
ultimately we all do often flit between
red and orange so some of you may now be
sitting in the red zone some of you may
be sitting in the orange zone and some
of you may actually feel quite
comfortable and feel that you're in the
yellow zone ultimately your goal and
your aim is to move from the red zone
over to the green zone the growths own
and manage your self in terms of when
you see yourself in that comfort zone
stepping out into that Bo zone across to
the learning and the gross thing so
moving on to the next slide we now have
another poll for you
so what shapes your confidence is it not
being prepared a lack of experience
other people or all of the above so
we're going to give you another minute
will to to let us know what shakes your
confidence
for some people it's because they feel
they're not prepared enough for some
people they feel that they just don't
have the right amount experience to do a
particular task or project for some
people it's other people how other
people may perceive them shapes their
confidence what other people may think
about them shapes their confidence or
for some of you it could be a
combination of all of the above
so I'm going to give you another minute
or two and just let us know your
thoughts
hence looking interesting okay
a number of you are this is this is
almost tying very interesting okay we're
almost there
ninety percent in brilliant will give it
another minute or two and of a couple of
seconds actually 95 percent of you are
there if you're very excellent
okay Mira will end the poll there so
what shakes your confidence so the first
thing what everybody has actually opted
for is not being prepared 42% of you
have said not being prepared shakes your
confidence
next 37% of you have actually said all
of the above so it's actually a
combination of not being prepared lack
of experience and other people's
thoughts about you or other people
around you that shakes your confidence
in third place lack of experience and
last but not least other people and
actually that's quite interesting
because that's more or less what I
expected to say and as we move on
through the rest is sorry to interrupt
sorry to interrupt I think we have 37
participants and only 19 have responded
it will be really good if the other
participants also respond because it
gives good data point to understand and
help us to develop more workshops and
webinars in line with what we see so we
would highly encourage all these
students who have not participated in
the poll to please what we can give one
more minute for that and I will put up
people back on the screen parent thanks
Mira so yeah it would have mirrors just
that it'd be absolutely fantastic if we
had to have more view so more people
waiting to come into the room let me
admit them apologies so it will be
absolutely fantastic if we could have a
few more votes coming in
anymore okay great
is he in coming in antastic keep it
coming
remember all of these polls on anonymous
okay nobody's going to know what you've
clicked so they were all anonymous
now what shakes your confidence think
about it and we're gonna create we can
see the number increasing now yeah
earlier there were 19 and we can see now
they are 25 under and it's going
increasing we don't seem to be having 10
more at least students good
so we have 25 out of 36 who have voted
we still seem to be having at least 10
more students who haven't yet voted
so in a moment we will be taking it
afresh the last result will not be taken
into consideration so it will be only
independent so this is like the fresh
one once we have at least 30 students
voted that'll be the voting thanks for
that moment Thank You Mira all right we
have 28 come on guys we could do a
little more yes 29 give us one more and
he can move on fantastic we have 30
Millions
fantastic I think it's okay Jackie we
move on yeah I'm ending the corner Thank
You students thank you very much for all
of those who have participated yep we've
got thirty votes in and again I'm going
to reread the response very close call
not being prepared still comes out on
top with 40% of you acknowledging that
not being prepared shapes your
confidence lack of experience 37% all of
the above 30% of you have come in and
said not being or all of the above in
some way or some form shaped your
confidence and 13% of you it's all about
other people other people shake your
confidence and you know not being
prepared I think is very much one that
shapes a lot of our confidence and I
even for myself I will say not being
prepared definitely is one that shakes
my confidence my SIA a thumbs up yeah
definitely and as we go through this we
are actually going to look at some of
these points in terms of how a lack or
confidence in these areas can hold you
back so let's look at how a lack of
confidence now holds you back so if
you're feeling any of these you know
what what what does it mean what does it
mean well when we lack confidence we
adopt certain types of behaviors as a
protection measure this measure we just
use it to keep us safe from exposure but
in reality these type of behaviors
actually hold us back from reaching our
true potential for example failing to
speak up at meetings or voice your
opinion how many times have you been in
a meeting or a situation where you said
to yourself he or she said what I was
going to say but she didn't speak up so
nobody knows how you think or what you
have to offer the issue with this is
that you run the risk of being invisible
in your organization and when it comes
to times for promotions and new job
opportunities you increase the risk of
being looked over because people just
don't know what you have to offer
because you never put your thoughts or
your views
or word another way how lack of
confidence can hold you back is
sometimes it makes it difficult for you
to communicate assertively you end your
sentences with questions you may use
qualifying words such as kind of sort of
and these words minimize the effect of
what you're saying your discomfort with
being assertive may lead you to talk too
much after you make a strong statement
instead of remaining quiet and waiting
for others to give their input another
big one is fear of failure if you step
outside your remit this will keep you in
your comfort zone where you feel safe
you know what you're doing at work
you're used to it in some respects
sometimes we all go on autopilot there
are some things that we are so used to
doing we feel comfortable we can almost
do them with our eyes closed however
when we get too cozy in this remit and
this is where you're in we look at the
zone you know when I ask you what zone
are you in this is where you're sitting
in that red zone you're feeling really
comfortable and you really don't want to
step out and the problem is that this
can actually prevent you from applying
for certain positions or seeking
stretcher assignments because in your
mind you're thinking you know what's the
point of going for that there's no need
I'm doing okay here but you know when
you want to change careers when you've
decided in your mind you know for some
reason you're not happy with where you
are you may feel that actually yes you
want to stretch but you're not sure what
steps to take to do it you're going to
have to step outside your comfort zone
the other thing that it can cause you to
do is to spend a lot of time questioning
what you are saying and doing the time
you spend questioning yourself could be
spent in a more productive way you get
this inner dialogue which might keep you
from taking positive action not only on
behalf or yourself but on behalf of
others now going back and thinking about
the pole where a number of you had
clicked
other people shake your confidence this
is where you may spend more time
focusing on what other people are saying
and doing then rather than what your own
potential and competence is you worry
that everyone is smarter than you or
more successful this focus on others is
a distraction and depletes the positive
energy you need to focus on your
ambition and reach your objections
objectives apologies a combination of
the above can affect your ability to
reach your full potential and work or
life and even if you have one of those
but it can impact your ability to move
forward and help you to get where you
really want to be so let's move on next
my saying share your thoughts lack of
confidence do any of you resonate with
these behaviors and some of you have
more or less said so in terms of the
poll that we looked at but do you
identify with these behaviors
any thoughts how are you feeling
can you see yourself yeah
I'm sure some of you can okay so what
we'll do now is we'll move on to what
can you do about it taking control of
your self-confidence what are you going
to do to take control well
lack of confidence we take effectual
decision-making abilities especially
when you're in a high-stress situations
so you really need to keep it in check
so that you can make decisions with a
clear mind taking control starts with
self-awareness the more self-aware you
become the more you start to recognize
negative habits that used
self-consciously
built up to cope with a lack of
confidence start listening to your
thoughts the next time you start to feel
a lack of confidence or self-doubt ask
yourself why do I feel this way what
it's fundamentally going on in my head
to make me react the way that I do take
time out for yourself
and start breaking down your thought
processes to find the root chord for
your actions and behaviors for some of
you you
may want to start writing a journal
about yourself analyzing why you have
such negative thoughts and when these
thoughts come up what you're trying to
do is you're trying to identify the
trigger what is it that's triggering
these thoughts and these feelings within
you what's happening immediately before
this sort of lack of confidence starts
to well up within you these feelings
these emotions then at the same time
whilst you've also identified these
triggers you want to think about things
that you do well things that you like
you also want to think about limitation
when you say to yourself I can't do this
or I can't go for that why all those
limitations there are they real or once
you've allowed to be placed there if you
really thought through some of these
limitations maybe you'll realize that
they aren't actually limitations but you
just need to find a way through them so
thinking about again strategies to help
you build self-confidence bad news is
there's no quick fix to building
self-confidence
there's no five minute or ten minutes
solution however the good news is that
you can increase your self-confidence by
having the focus and determination to
carry things through so what can you do
to build your self-confidence well here
are some steps that you can take moving
on to the next slide thank you you can
create an achievement log think about
your life so far and list ten of the
best things you've achieved remind
yourself of the success you've already
had look at your strengths think about
your strengths use a technique like a
SWOT analysis now some of you may be
familiar with SWOT analysis it stands
for strengths weaknesses opportunities
and threats and it's a tool it's what is
a tool used by businesses to analyze
their processes procedures and
competitors however they can also be
used in a personalized way to help you
spot opportunities you didn't know
existed
so when it comes to strengths
you need to do or you might want to
think about doing is make a list of
these think about what skills or tasks
that are your strong points your unique
selling points but also think about all
those tasks others say you are good at
and don't just restrict it to the
workplace there will be things maybe
that you do outside you might be good at
certain games at doing other activities
and hobbies list them all weaknesses
what tasks do you avoid because you
don't feel confident doing them
what are your negative work habits or
traits that can hold you back
opportunities is there a way that you
can build an opportunity for yourself by
taking advantage of your strengths or
eliminating weaknesses if your industry
growing there may be an opportunity
there
threats lists threats that might be
standing in the way of your goals what
obstacles are you facing at work or
challenges think about them what
challenges are there in transitioning to
a new role for you list is you need to
identify them in order to tackle them
what problems could your weaknesses
cause if you don't address them then
think about what actions you're going to
take to minimize threats and weaknesses
which in turn will increase your
confidence learn to celebrate and
develop your strengths and find ways to
improve or manage your weaknesses now
there's a whole sort of exercise and a
matrix that goes around doing this
exercise so if you'd like to learn more
about swats or going to them into more
detail feel free to book a session with
a career coach who can talk to you
through this process in more detail and
work with you on it so let's look at
some other things that you can do well
you can work on small things
goal-setting people make the mistake or
starting with big projects or tasks
which can be overwhelming and daunting
and if you do have a big project ratash
you're working on
I suggest breaking them down into
smaller chunks setting small or
attainable goals and getting into the
habit of setting them and achieving them
this constant sort of meeting the
challenges that you set yourself it
doesn't matter how small they are they
help build your confidence incrementally
and gradually then you can start to
build up to larger goals and you won't
feel as fearful because you started to
conquer small things it may be five
minute ten minute goal but get into the
habit of just setting and achieving
goals now this one may seem strange to
you but I don't know how many of you
work with a clear desk so it might seem
like an amazing small thing but
cluttered desk cluttered mind and when
we've got a lot going on in our mind
sometimes it's really difficult to feel
confident because we start to feel that
our emotions our thoughts our workload
is getting out of control and we need to
feel away to feel back in control again
so having a clear desk often helps you
to declutter your mind I know that when
I worked in a corporate world we had a
clear desk policy I'm sure many of you
may also have a clear this with your
best policy where you work get into the
act of doing the first time we do
something we've never done before we'll
bring out our fear factor to the
forefront but in order to progress you
need to take a leap of faith when in the
work environment or meetings rather than
worrying you won't say the right thing
or being concerned about what other
people think
ask questions listen and respond in an
objective way ultimately this is all
about you building up your confidence
don't worry about what other people are
thinking and doing just worry and focus
on yourself
so what else can you do leave your
comfort zone you have no idea how
resilient you are until you make it a
point to know be willing to take some
risks
look at risk as negatives but rather as
learning opportunities you know
sometimes the fear factor of just doing
something and thinking I'll make a
mistake I'll make a mistake well yet
sometimes we do make mistakes we all
learn from our mistakes so don't worry
about it next this is one that's going
to be challenging for some of you but
work on your mindset positive thinking
eliminate those negative thoughts if you
believe that you can achieve something
then you will be able to do so but you
need to be aware of that so talk that in
a voice that might say to you I've never
done this before I'm not sure I can do
this and if you're saying it out loud
try to learn to correct him positive
affirmations of things that you can do
to help you to grow your mindset when
you've got this fixed mindset of I can't
do this I've never done this and you put
a lot of negatives in the way it's
almost like a wall a barrier that
prevents you from moving forward so the
positive affirmations there's research
to say that when you repeat something
enough times that it gets within you
that it actually helps to build up your
faith and confidence that you can do it
so rather than saying I've never done
this before not sure I can do it try
replacing it with thoughts or with words
saying I'm open to trying something new
and I'm confident that I can learn from
this experience whatever the outcome if
you find it challenging to communicate
assertively tell yourself I'm confident
in my ability to communicate clearly and
directly to others next empower yourself
with knowledge often our lack of
confidence is due to our lack of
knowledge we feel that we don't know
enough about our subject so we are
unsure of whether or not we can do
something by becoming more knowledgeable
in a particular area you'll become more
confident and feel competent at doing
something set aside time to research
study
and practice in the area where you want
to become more competent it's not just
gonna happen overnight you're going to
have to put some work into it so that's
how you can start and some of the things
you can look at to help start to build
up your confidence
moving on to communicating with
confidence your voice is an instrument
and that's exactly how you should look
at your voice there are two sides to
building confidence although the
ultimate aim is to feel more confident
within yourself and your abilities
it's also worth considering how you can
appear more confident to other people
what you say how you say it transmits a
great deal about your level of
confidence we often struggle to
articulate our thoughts clearly when we
lack confidence so learn to speak slowly
when you're in a meeting when you're in
an interview scenario when you're at a
meet-up even think about the pace of
your speech we often speak quickly when
we are nervous a person in authority
speak slowly and actually gives off a
vibe of confidence
think about your tone of voice
high-pitched voices are often said to
indicate nervousness that kind of
squeaky high-pitched voice vary your
pitch and your tone make your
conversations interesting by injecting
variety and avoid sounding monotone try
to avoid non-word you know those words
such as they're called filler phrases
you know you know that's what they call
them project your voice speak at an
audible volume make yourself easily
heard and understood and this is
particularly important than those of you
who do phone interview there's nothing
worse than an interviewer constantly
having to ask you to speak up or trying
to decipher what you're saying make it
easier for them there's a couple of one
or two well extra ones that I thought
I'd mention express ideas respectfully
we can all be in situations or scenarios
where things can get a bit heated if
you're engaging
with someone whether in a work setting
Meetup or forum where views may be
expressed which you don't agree with
rather than keeps silent you can still
be assertive and stick to your
principles and values you can put your
view across by expressing I see this a
little differently and then going into
your view or your perspective or you
might say to the other person help me to
understand your reason for thinking and
then expand if you get into the systems
and you're feeling stress remember to
just take a deep breath and take it slow
just slow down deep breaths until you
can regain your thoughts and regain your
emotions and your confidence so moving
on to looking confident what does your
body language say about you our body
language can signal to people around us
exactly how we are feeling we
unconsciously move in a way that
reflects our mental state confident body
language can change the way people
perceive you so be aware of your overall
manner how you behave will transmit a
feeling of confidence to others posture
if you are standing up research has
shown that when people stand tall in a
position of strength their inner
feelings begin to change the your idea
is that you're supposed to sort of stand
tall and imagine you've got a string at
the top of your head pulling you up so
that your posture remains upright avoid
standing in a submissive position so
that's what your legs cross your arms
folded in front of you that's considered
to be more of a submitted submissive
position when you're sitting remember to
sit with your back straight feet planted
on the fur on the floor firmly this is
seen to be a good sitting posture if
while I'm talking to you here
you all saw me go like this like this
slumped it wouldn't project a very
confident view of what I'm saying you'd
all be thinking why is she hiding why
she sort of slumped so think about it
be confident in how you project yourself
you may not feel it so you probably all
heard about fake it until you make it
well do what you've got to do you may
not feel it in word but it all starts
with how you're projecting yourself
outwardly okay so we're going to move on
to the next slide facial expressions
research indicates that 80% or at least
80% of communication comes non-verbally
facial expressions convey a great deal
of information so be aware of your
standard facial expression do you look
Stern do you get comments from friends
and colleagues at work about your facial
extra there's expressions be mindful of
them also be mindful of habits for
example do you touch your face a lot
while you speak as this indicates
anxiety or nervousness some of you might
be fitters not even aware that you're
doing it so do you fidget tap your foot
on the ground or trim your fingers on
the table pay attention to what triggers
that fidgeting do you is it because you
actually feel a bit of a sort of lack of
confidence or nervousness or self-doubt
welling up within you that you sort of
start to move into fidget mode start
becoming more self aware of how you
behave and in what situations or
scenarios you're behaving like that
sometimes these acts come across as a
sign of nervousness even when you don't
intend them to and you'll be in
situations where it's the last thing you
want to project especially if your aim
is to project and come off as confident
these movements can also take away the
message you're trying to communicate
Hugh audience and may distract people
from getting to know you if you do
engage sometimes people engage with
their hands and you know a lot of us do
sort of this and we're quite
illustrative when we're talking and
speaking or animated form where we're
friends and colleagues use open gestures
keep your movements relaxed using the
palms of your hands and it's often seen
as I've got nothing to hide motions so
you just remember sometimes even though
you're not speaking
you silently give off signals by the way
that you move and people can often be
watching you so in terms of your whole
persona not just how you're projecting
yourself but also what you do with your
hands and your feet and your fingers
learn to smile okay confident people
smile as they have nothing to hide okay
let's move on to building confidence for
an interview
absolutely absolutely key planning and
preparation yeah we often feel less
confident about new or potentially
difficult situation so an important
factor in developing confidence is
planning and preparing for the unknown
being able to react calmly to the
unexpected is a sign of confidence so
when you're preparing for an interview
spend time thinking about the questions
you may be asked practice your answers
in front of a mirror with friends or a
career coach and gain their feedback
plan in advance about how you're going
to travel there how long will your
journey take what are you going to wear
don't leave it till the last minute for
those of you who might be traveling by
car think about plan B what happens if
you get up on the morning to drive to
that interview and your car won't start
what should plan B don't leave it until
the last minute and I don't know if any
of you have had that experience but I'm
sure if you have you will know the way
how it knocks your self-confidence when
you're having to deal with this
unexpected incident be mindful of how
you come across while you're in the
reception waiting area the interview
begins as soon as you arrive in the
building now someone could be observing
you before they actually come out and
call you so think about how you see how
you're expressing yourself are you on
your mobile phone what are you doing
just be aware of your surroundings and
who could be watching so moving next
slide is visualize your success
leading up to the interview takes some
time to actually visualize the interview
going well thinking about how you're
going to protect you project yourself
how you plan to walk in think about all
the steps from the moment you get there
start to visualize sitting opposite the
panel or the individual if you've got an
assessment to take think about it and
visualize it going well from the start
remember to know your value remember
your self-worth on what you can do for
the company yes you want to job you want
to transition into that field but
remember they've called you because
clearly there's something that they've
seen there's some values you have some
skills that the organization sees that
you could potentially be a good fit so
when you go there
know your value what you were and also
think about context and timing don't be
afraid of silence in interviews if
you're asked to describe a problem you
salt don't just launch into response
from frame your answer to the question
giving some context around it so how did
the problem come about what action did
you take to solve it how did you help me
solve it and what was the final outcome
if you rush through the situation too
quickly the interviewer may think that
actually it wasn't a big deal to start
with and won't give it the g-value in
consideration it's worth so let me get
your thoughts how much time do you spend
preparing for interviews type a few
words in the chat how much time do you
spend preparing for interviews do you
prepare the night before do you prepare
a couple of weeks before how much time
do you prepare so in preparing let's
know your thoughts yeah there isn't
necessarily
correct amount of time but I just want
you to sort of really think about the
amount of effort and time you're
spending on your interviews for some of
you it might be just not quite the role
that you want but nevertheless even if
it's not quite your ideal job use it as
practice okay treat it as if you were
going for that ideal role and prepare in
exactly the same way a manner so
confidence in the workplace moving on to
learn first impressions count and they
really do so whether you are changing
careers or starting a new job working in
a field you're familiar with amongst the
excitement there's usually an element of
nervousness about venturing into the
unknown territory surveys have
demonstrated a strong correlation
between confidence and Occupational
success key thing is set the tone from
the start
spread positive energy start by
introducing yourself and getting to know
the people around you don't hide away in
a corner trying to figure everything out
for yourself find out early on what
everyone does when you're new everyone
gives you a lot of leeway an
understanding that you won't really know
the processes and how things work around
the office or wherever you are so allow
yourself to take advantage of that and
try and absorb as much as you can around
your new settings or in your workplace
article questions show curiosity how or
why something is being done so you can
understand the process in order to feel
more confident in your new role you need
you not only need to understand what you
do but where you fit in in the
organizational structure which teams or
departments are you most likely to
engage with and what do they do so let's
go on to some takeaway points for you
takeaway points remember achievements
remind yourself of the successes you've
already had if you keep that lock when
you're going through that moment where
you're feeling low
you can always take it out and read
through your achievements and remind
yourself of your successes you do have
the confidence to do what you can do you
do have the abilities when it comes to
communicating remember communication is
key okay
speak slowly with an audible voice
calmness betrays confidence mind your
body language
remember to intentionally use your body
language to feel more confident stand
tall remain have eye contact
you can even mirror the body language
sometimes of the interviewer however you
need to know when to do it and when not
to
next you can think about booking a
coaching session there are a number of
us here myself and my colleague mirrors
on the line who can help you we can help
you practice building your
self-confidence we can help you with the
SWOT analysis we can help people with
interview practice and even with
questions and answers and feedback so do
users we're here we're a resource
provided by Udacity when you're in the
workplace spread positive energy by
setting the tone from the start
nothing worse than being in a place for
two to three months and then starting to
ask questions at that point people will
be wondering why you didn't ask things
before people will be thinking you
should know this by now don't let your
lack of confidence hold you back from
finding out what really goes on in the
workplace what you need to know to do
your job well and Excel so that's going
to be the end of this presentation and
now that we drawn to an end I'd like you
all to share your thoughts let us know
if you've got any question and answers
about building self-confidence you know
feel free to drop a line or two about
your experiences have you got any
interviews coming up just give us your
thoughts
Merilee any questions coming in
yep so we've got about another 10
minutes left so let us know I will
unmute okay we have the first question
from Mohamed how to say no to people
he's asking you and me so go ahead
Jackie Jackie I think you have muted
yourself Jackie so yeah how to say no
that's always a challenging one you know
there is a polite way to say no in terms
of I mean I guess you're talking about
are you talking about in terms of saying
no to doing a job it's always good to
give an explanation as to why you can't
do something is it because you've got
too much on your plate and therefore in
order to do something well you don't
have capacity to do it you know in that
case I think you just need to be able to
demonstrate some context around it
rather than just saying no you know
can't do it give a bit of an a
background explanation why can't you do
it well you've got a number of things on
your task you might not be able to do it
now but when can you do it
when can you fit it in always learn to
try and phrase a Porno into a positive I
can't do it now I can't do it this way
but I'm likely to have capacity to do it
next week or at such-and-such a time or
I can't do it but I'll see if one of my
other colleagues has capacity to look at
it for you or I will put you in contact
with somebody who might be able to help
you so you know there are always ways to
start thinking about how can I turn this
this which might look like a negative by
saying no straight away into a positive
does that help
okay Jackie we have another question
which says do you have a personal
experience with career
change this question is from Ken so Ken
yes I myself have a personal experience
then at the beginning I don't not sure
if you were already admitted to the room
but I have been working in the legal
field as a lawyer for over 15 years and
even within legal field I've changed
different expertise or areas of niche so
I've worked in regulatory I've worked in
with corporates doing high-end banking
transactions and then I've also worked
for consumers and even within the legal
sector the transition is very different
I've had to learn and I will say when
the key thing is learning to deal with
different stakeholders
what's your stakeholders expectations
when you join an organization and you
transition because the way how you're
used to dealing and handling people in
your previous role can be very very
different in your new role so learn to
understand their perspective what are
they used to dealing with or how are
they used to people engaging with them
sometimes you can just pick up the phone
for some people but some people I found
they didn't like that approach they
wanted me to put diary time in with them
so that you know we could sit down and
go through things so that's one change
in then now I don't do so much legal
work I do legal consultant work for time
to time but now I've transitioned almost
into a full-time business and
development coach and my skill sets now
I'm having to use aren't there
transferable using a lot of my
transferable skills but they are very
different I'm not in the advising field
anymore before I would advise people
being a coach is a different perspective
you know you for example as a student or
the coach is the one who leads the
agenda I'm not leading the agenda
anymore so you know it is very much you
know a learning process even for me I've
been through that learning process
learning to engage with different people
meet their expectations and that's what
I did I went out and I spoke to as many
people as I could when I first joined
because people are also looking at you
when you
they're looking at you and thinking well
what are they know will they fit in you
know
are they approachable are they easy to
get on whoa
will you know will this be challenging
for us so remember a lot of people that
you're when you're going into an area a
lot of people are also might be nervous
or edgy a new person joining a team so
there are expectations on both sides but
you know all I can say really is if
you've got questions that you think
you're concerned about deal with them
from the star you know set the tone
yourself don't wait for somebody else to
carve out your tone and and and you know
direct your career path you need to step
out and do it for yourself so guys we
are getting a lot of questions here we
may not be able to cover all of them but
I'm just picking up so that each one off
is different from the rest and if we
don't pick up a few don't mind that you
can always come on the career hotline
session every coach comes once in a week
for one our on student hub on the
courier section to give career advice
so Jackie another interesting question
is how to stay self confident in a
situation of incivility in a workplace
would you like to take that yes sorry
how to stay self confident in a
situation of incivility in the workplace
yeah and you know sometimes it can get
quite hostile in certain environments
it's it's not nice I've been in I've
been in two meetings where I know that
you know the other side or the other
party were engaging with is getting
quite tense and heated and some
crosswords can be said and I've often
found silence can be the best tool so
rather than just gush out and say your
thoughts and it goes back to my point
about being calm and saying respectfully
you know I don't see things from your
perspective if you know you feel that
the on civility is being directed as you
the way how I would recommend
approaching it is don't say anything
about it in the meeting but after the
meeting ask to speak with a person pull
them aside and explain to them that you
know you felt that there was you know a
bit of friction between you and you'd
like to resolve it if you feel that they
didn't speak to you appropriately that
would be the time to tell them on a
one-on-one rather than doing it in a
surrounding where other people may here
can often make people feel more as you
know can often make people's tempers
fray more and for the situation to get
out of hand or more fraud so uncivil are
clever to deal with but I definitely
recommend knocking them on the head sin
rather than later you may allow it to
take place you know one time two times
but then if you're finding it a repeated
behavior pattern I would definitely
recommend having some out time whether
it's once one with that person if you
don't feel comfortable for one to one
setting up a meeting with that person
between yourself and you know whether
you feel it's at a level that you need
to engage your manager in and mention it
to a manager then you know by all means
you know if you feel your manager is
someone that you can provide in and
speak to about it do let them know
what's going on I just don't feel that
and it's unfortunate but I don't feel
that people should have to face that
every day because it totally knocks your
confidence I can see that when you're
feeling that you're going into an area
you feel that somebody's going to have a
barrage of things to say to you you know
I've worked for people who have you know
sort of given that element of fear when
you go and you sit down you thinking
they're not in a good mood today and
what I intend to do is just focus focus
on what I need to do and I need to get
done you know ultimately you need to set
the tone for how you want to be seen and
not how you know they want to treat you
so Jackie as a follow-up of that
question there's a comment from legatee
say
in that what if the person is your boss
so legatee the rules are the same
sorry Jackie I'm taking this because I
have experienced this in my own life
okay
the rules are the same you just go out
and have a coffee with your boss
at first he may or she may not like it
or like it depends on what kind of a
personality he or she is but he or she
will definitely appreciate your upfront
Ness your straightforwardness and at
worst what can happen you have got it
off your heart you are fresh again with
the clear and positive mind if this
continues if you until you two get the
same experience over and over again then
this needs to go to a second level in a
formal kind of a conversation now we
have only two minutes left Jackie and we
still have couple of questions so I'll
just pick up one last question which
would be um again it's like a tease
question can low self-esteem lead to
self-confidence can low self-esteem lead
to lack of confidence you know I'd say
and you have obviously low
self-confidence where you know you're
looking at your abilities yeah you know
so what can you you're more concerned
about what you can do and with
self-esteem you're more concerned about
what other people think about you you
know your self-esteem both are often
seen hand-in-hand normally if you are
building up yourself confident you'll
often find that your self-esteem is
uplifted as well you know things like
self-esteem you can add certain things
so often how you dress as well on a day
can affect you so some people are for
example are frightened to wear bold
colors because they think well I don't
want to wear red or yellow because I
will stand out well you know if red or
yellow makes you feel happy you feel
that it's a warning color to you it
lifts your spirits your self-esteem then
do it you know it's very very difficult
when you're in a situation where you've
got low confidence and low self-esteem
and you know it's something that you
need to build up gradually and talking
to someone about it is definitely you
know a key do you have someone that you
feel that you can confide in do you you
know another key thing you'll say is
find confident people so we all know
confident people and there is a saying
by a motivational speaker John Rowe is
that you basically are the example or
you are similar to the five people you
spend the most time with so if there's
somebody that you admire who exudes
confidence learn to spend some time with
them in their presence
because that rubs off on you you know is
it legatee you asked it legatee you know
by all means you know for a deeper
conversation and one-on-one with that
with those issues and I definitely
suggest booking some time with one of
the career coaches because that's not
something that's just going to go like
that it's something that you know you
need to work on and it needs to be
tailored for you so you know I'm
hopefully that you've got some sessions
and do please book a session with a
career coach or you can email one of us
confidently afterwards you've got mirror
here and myself so you know please do
reach out to us so that brings us to the
end of this webinar Jacqui via already
or shot by a couple of minutes and there
are some students who are whose answers
questions have not been answered please
feel free to come on the career hotline
chat we all of us are there for one hour
every week and we'd be more than happy
to chat and connect with y'all again
over to you Jackie for the end note okay
for the end note the last slide because
I just wanted to thank you all for
attending today's webinar and wanted to
let you all know about the next upcoming
webinar so on the 7th of January and
there's going to be a webinar by Brett
Ellis one of our colleagues and he's
going to be talking about new year new
job search strategy so I'm sure a lot of
you are going to be interested in that
so please if you're able to join Brett
on 7th for January
okay and thank you over
much for taking the time here I hope you
found this session helpful you know
please feel free to like Mira has said
you know we all take time an hour in the
chat room both myself and mirror or in
there at different times on a Thursday
so today that's your chat room day
mirror has already done hers I won't be
doing mine today because mine is during
this time slot but I will be in the chat
room tomorrow from 2:00 to 3:00 p.m.
which is standard time I'm actually
located in the UK so you know please
forward some of your you know your
comments your questions I'll be in the
chat room and hopefully I can answer a
lot more for you all then so thank you
Tamara my co-host has been fantastic
helping me along with this webinar and
thanks you very much
all and all the best for 2020 thank you
all bye-bye have a great year ahead
thank you bye bye